good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday it has
been
i'm literally out of breath such an
eventful morning here at morning toast
hq
as you guys can see there has been like
this structure building behind us
a scaffolding a scaffolding and it has
been so torturous with all the
construction
even some days we've been treated to
some extra special guests on the show if
you watch on the video
you've seen some people in the
background like doing their thing
so this morning we got here and it was
literal fort knox like the craziest
construction sounds ever and we're like
how are we supposed to
podcast but you know i opened up the
window i made an appointment right
outside
right outside i opened the window i made
an agreement everyone was so lovely
and i feel like we made a lot of new
friends and they have agreed to pause
the construction for 40 minutes so we
can podcast for you guys
tomorrow i do believe they're gonna work
they told us only two more days here so
tomorrow we're gonna podcast from home
just so we can share quality audio
but this morning we were here we were
dressed and we were like we have to make
it work
so we struck a deal we got 40 quiet
minutes and we're gonna make the most of
that i literally walked into the tank
and i said i'm asking for 40 minutes of
silence in exchange for some ice cold
water bottles
and a lifelong friendship and they
agreed to it they did and they were so
lovely
so we have 40 minutes to talk to you
guys but never a dull moment here at
tmt hq no never a dull moment actually
yesterday we were spared because we
started so early because we were
interviewing the bold type girls after
they did gma we started everything
earlier
so when we finished the show the noises
were
crazy they hadn't started yet so we have
to figure that's the time that we
normally do the show it's only two more
days that we need to figure out but i
think tomorrow just to ensure quality
audio
podcasts from home and then thursday
maybe we'll do a little earlier or find
their lunch break
that totally works for me because i'm
going out tonight and like a podcast
from home maybe at like 11 o'clock
tomorrow
just really works with like my drinking
schedule so i for one am not angry at
all
okay i'm glad that you're not angry and
you are going out tonight and i
am styling you because oh yeah i forgot
we're doing a super fun patreon episode
tonight where i am styling claudia for a
night out in my
grandma's finest i mean i'm absolutely
frightened
for what you're gonna pick out only
because i have a sickening closet i mean
i did a closet tour and a closet clean
out on the patreon
i have a sickening closet full of things
that don't fit me so like you can pick
out whatever you want but there's really
five blouses that fit me right now
well i'm gonna pick stuff out and it's
not like here put this on that's what
you're wearing like it has to work with
you so
i work with the client and i'm so
excited
to smile i'm excited is that i get to do
it on the next vlog and i'm going to be
styling
you and you're going to be looking like
a chooky
ass tic talker okay i'll take it
speaking of chew game
i copied you i got one of these like
beaded charms for
the cell phones that addison ray has i
got mine from shopjillon alley which is
where yours is from we're literally
twins same phone case
i know strings i'll fully take
responsibility like i copied everything
you did i'm so unoriginal
um but i do feel like so unbelievably
cool yeah that
you really can't put a price on that you
know no you look so cool like when i say
today i was like whoa like like who am i
like
oh my god my phone is just like dangling
from my rest
i hate to see it i'm just like such a
dangly little fragile little girl
you're so fragile so fragile um we have
a great show for you guys there was
really nothing on tv last night so
there's no tv recap but we've got celeb
news
gossip uh sure we've got some like book
updates because i finished my book as
you guys know romanov empress the more
time that i've had away from it the more
i'm regarding it i rated it a four
initially might turn that into a five
um but then i started a book i just
needed to switch gears and i saw that
you were reading the new lauren
weisberger book
how did you know i was you like struck
me on goodreads goodreads yeah well i
just opened goodreads
because that's where i go to find my
next book it said claudia started the
new lauren weiss burger book which is
where the grass is green and the girls
are pretty
and right that's the title i have
literally no idea it's just like a
really i just said it's the book
from the devil where's the girl the new
one the new exactly and i saw you
started it and i
wanted to read it so i just switched
gears and i started that
but because i had such a busy day
yesterday i fell asleep at 10 o'clock i
worked out twice yesterday we got up so
early for the bull type
of course we mentioned on the show that
we were recording another interview and
because we mentioned it
didn't even say it just canceled the
universe said
reschedule that's why like we literally
never say our guest because
when we do nine times out of ten that's
the one that has to reschedule like
foreign so
you probably already can tell from the
title there's no guest on today's show
no it's just two big fools two big fools
podcast episode title 100 but two big
fools with 40 minutes of quiet
40 minutes of silence honestly the
silence is so
serious you guys we've been living with
a jackhammer
that was really good that was good
literally is what it sounded like yeah
yeah you could be a jackhammer when you
grow up
thank you i want to be a jackie hammer
um honestly i feel like we should just
get into it so that we don't waste any
precious time of this beautiful
serene silence okay we could get we
could get right into it but we have no
tv recaps if there's anything
that you like want to share with the
class anything you're feeling anything
you did sure i mean literally i spent
the whole day yesterday memorizing that
monologue from the crown
camilla is who i want i that is where my
problem is all your videos
who my loyalty is with i saw you not the
woman you
married don't bring the boys into this
all right
no sorry i [ __ ] it up let me start
again i saw your video let me start
again
okay camilla is who i want that is where
my priority is
that is who my loyalty is not the mother
of your
children don't bring the boys into this
all right
not the woman you married i refuse to be
blamed any longer for this group test
swiss alliance
i wash my hands of it and seen
it's like i honestly in my soul like i
genuinely refuse to be blamed any longer
for this grotesque alliance like that is
my new
like motto for life it's so true like i
[ __ ] refuse like leave me the [ __ ]
alone
i refuse to be blind any longer for this
grotesque miss lions grotesque miss
alliances are
are the worst oh and you know speaking
of grotesque alliances it really reminds
me of sorry nicholas and alexandro
what a grotesque miss alliance that's
you just hate to see it
you hate to see it no no like because of
this grotesque miss alliance like
the romanovs were done it was due to
it so that's literally what i did
yesterday and why i have nothing to
contribute
to the like day you were working on your
art
literally like i practiced that
monologue so many times
i want to go out for you know season
seven prince charles like i
i think this is up against dominic west
and i could take him
100 100 everyone would love to see that
one everyone
okay well i guess without further ado to
do where are you not here because we
knew it was going to be chaotic today
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
public goods literally my favorite
company
um okay so public goods is the one-stop
shop for sustainable
high-quality everyday essentials made
from clean ingredients at an affordable
price
they make everything from coffee to
toilet paper shampoo to pet food
they have everything in their store and
it's all thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer
so rather than buying a bunch of
products from different brands public
good members can buy
all of their essentials premium
essentials in one place with beautiful
streamlined aesthetic
they search the globe to find clean
healthy eco-friendly and innovative
products
like i use the um surface cleaner almost
every day and the hand soap is in my
guest room
first of all guest bedroom excuse me i
don't i mean no sorry guess bathroom i
don't have a guest bedroom um all their
products smell amazing
and they're great for the environment
and they're clean but the reason why i
love them because i'm not
that eco-conscious is they're literally
just the best products like they smell
amazing they work really well the
aesthetic is
everything and then it's just an added
bonus that they're super eco-friendly
and if you care about the environment
like why don't you want fabulous things
too you know
knowing what's in your products and
where they came from is super important
small changes in the way we shop can
make a big impact on personal health and
the world at large
so we have a great deal for you guys if
you want to get 15 off your first public
goods order with no minimum purchase
that's right they're so confident
that you will love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you 15
to spend on your first purchase you know
what else is a great product that ben
has been loving they're olive oil have
you used it
yes stunning bottle i'm like literally
in a garden in the hamptons
and it's like premium olive oil ben is
obsessed with it it is premium olive oil
i i was hooked on it for a while so you
have nothing to lose go to
publicgoods.com
toast or use the code toast at checkout
that's p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com forward slash toast to receive
15 off your first order public goods is
everything of the sort love it okay
first story a little gymnastics news
it's not called gymnastics
simone miles he's just made history as
the first
woman to land her your chanco double
pike in competition
it's a sickening vault that typically
women don't do in competition it's
too dangerous and not only did she
successfully do it
she stuck the [ __ ] land she stuck it
yeah and apparently she's just like so
far ahead of every single other gymnast
like going in the world
and now the judges are actually
receiving criticism for judging her
school like her scores are too low and
she got like a 6.6 for
landing that sickening vault yes i
believe the reasoning is because they
there are certain tricks that they
encourage you not to do because they're
too dangerous and sometimes they don't
even let you like submit
and perform and i guess they don't want
to encourage that but like sorry when
you're the top athlete in your game like
you have to constantly be raising the
bar
literally and that's what simone biles
is doing and honestly we're so lucky to
have her because like
you know the olympics i'm first of all
so excited for the olympics i just i
love
being a part of something that's like
how we were just talking about
eurovision
um and it's like you know when your team
sucks it's like embarrassing and
simone biles ensures that like we don't
suck you know we're so lucky to have her
she is already like the most decorated
iconic gymnastics and she's going into
another olympics like
performing porchenkos per chain like
your tanko
your tranco like i want to do a your
tanko so
that's where my goals are at yeah and
also like i just i'm not here like
judge judging judges judging
in a judgmental way i'm just not here
for it like it just reminds me
of the ticket and i understand that they
don't want to encourage dangerous moves
but like gymnastics is dangerous
period right but these girls have
mastered it
let me just say something that's like
really indicative of how [ __ ] up the
us gymnastics team is like
okay so they're like so concerned about
everyone's safety
and they're like not letting people
challenge themselves in their
techniques but like literally like
nobody cared about like what larry now
yeah yeah no
larry nasser was just like running
rampant but they're trying to protect
the girls but you didn't protect the
girls jeremy you're like
fake pr on how you care about the
gymnast because you don't because you
don't give simone a 10
and move on yeah and seriously like it's
not called gymnastics
it's not called gymnastics it's such a
good movie like we're so
unworthy of a movie like that compelling
and that beautiful yeah i totally agree
i adore that movie like and
i only watch it like once every five
years and every time i do i'm like i
should watch this more often
you should watch it again like in the
lead up to the olympics and there are so
many iconic
like um actresses in it like joanne is
that her name the one who was like mean
it's not called gymnastics yeah
she's sugar from glee like she's an
iconic actress yeah
and oh jeff bridges iconic iconic
nasty lucan's in it oh yeah she made a
cameo
and the the main character she looks
like hillary swank but she's not him no
she's hilary swank's like illegitimate
daughter
younger sister yeah no it's crazy but
now she's like a star of some tnt show
oh is she yeah like i i hadn't heard of
her or her work since stick it and then
like a few years ago she got one of
those cop shows that just like remain on
tv even though nobody watches them
and it seems to be pretty popular oh
good i'm happy for her and i'm happy for
simone biles for just raising the bar
yet again give her the accolades she
deserves can't wait to watch her at the
olympics
this is literally like that michelle
obama meme like look at you
raising the bar constantly like that is
literally this the mobiles 100
100 100 percent yeah
yeah also her boyfriend was
complimenting her on instagram
saying uh no comparison he's a former
and he's an nfl player
which leads into our next story because
luanne della steps his new man is a
former nfl player oh my god
former i was like she's not dating a
current nfl player like
the cougar life knows no bounds luanne's
latest mystery man
is a former nfl player she met in mexico
page six is told page six reported back
in april that the rahone star had a
vacation fling while in tulum that was
just a short-term thing
but it seems things have picked up again
between them and he's been snapped with
her gallivanting around the city
and smooching on a boat in the hamptons
while our source wouldn't budge on
coughing up his name we're told the hunk
was the manager of her hotel in hook
tulum
and that he is a former professional
soccer player and kicker for the miami
dolphins so
oh wait both both former soccer former
football
you know i hope that when i am at
luann's age i am pulling dick
left right and center and like she's
always just like finding these random
men to hang out with her
and honestly i have so much respect for
it because it's not easy at any age it's
really not
and sh and i think all the other women
are constantly in awe of her too like
just
rolling up with these like guys even
though garth like isn't my type at
all like all the women seem to be like
really into him so i'm
i have a lot of respect for the hustle i
really really do i really do and i love
i have a lot of respect for happy lou
and when she's in a relationship she's
always a happy lou
yeah i just like i i do worry about her
like constantly
yeah you know like that's the famous
episode of real houses at beverly hills
like what keeps you up at night
and i'm constantly kept up by luanne
like i just i hope that she's okay and i
feel like you know
what we see on the show is like not
really who she is in real life and like
what she's currently up to
you think so do you know this for
certain no i'm just saying that's what i
feel
okay but sometimes like you have like so
you're saying you think in real life
she's off the wagon i know i don't think
that that's what i'm saying i'm sorry i
just really hope that she's not oh yeah
same
same but i don't know her display this
season i have full confidence in her me
too and i have been
like uh on the luan boat for a really
long time and then she like made it
really hard when she was like struggling
with her sobriety and was like coming
for bethany when bethany was literally
the only person on planet earth helping
her
um that made it really hard but now that
bethany's out of the picture i
am i really love luanne i really do like
i'm one of her biggest champions i i
that's safe to say yeah no i i would
agree
and i'm glad she's found a man i'm glad
she's found a man who seems to be she
loves a fitness man
she does but she's very athletic like
yeah every season she's more toned
you think she can't get in better shape
and then she shows up next season
looking even more toned 100
and i just show up every season looking
more tan because if you can't tone it
tan it yes wise words are ready for our
next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by echelon
yes yes it is how did you know that well
i just have a
special sense for those things when
you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
instructors like nicole griffin and
michael brown alongside a community of
25 000 members
who can give you that extra push and
echelon is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment the workout community
and an instructor's motivation right in
the comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists
with echelon you can work out any time
day or night and crush your fitness
goals
just pick a class climb the leaderboard
cheer each other on and give it your all
you can track your workouts and your
progress to reach your fitness goals
because echelon certified fitness
instructors are supportive
engaging and fun and they really know
how to get you moving they have a full
range of affordable workout equipment
including stationary bikes
smart rowers sleek fitness screens or
the auto folding treadmill
all connected with the echelon
experience rowers are like the new thing
like everyone is obsessed with them and
echelon of her makes amazing ones
you can get around the around-the-clock
classes for for the family including
full-body workout programs that keep you
coming back one membership covers a
family of five
so really is the most affordable way to
work out at home and now our listeners
can get a special
podcast offer from echelon for a limited
time only start your 30-day risk-free
trial offer with echelon's ex3 bike
for just one dollar a special risk-free
offer for 30 days with echelon's ex3
bike for only one dollar to start plus
free shipping
the only way to get this special offer
is by going to echelonfit.com
toast this is how it's spelled e c h e l
o n
f i t dot com slash toast echelon fit
dot com slash toast
that's a truly incredible offer that's a
truly great sponsor
yeah next we're so blessed we are so
blessed so much
over two for two great sponsors that i
wholeheartedly like want to go home and
use
just wait for the third one just wait
just wait just wait
okay if you're ready to sign on
am i gonna smell it you are okay but i
don't wanna give it away okay okay okay
we gotta work up to it
travis barker says the plane crash
served his rehab to kick his opioid
addiction
in a new interview the blink 182 drummer
detailed his recovery from the 2008
crash
which killed two of his close friends
and said it forced him to stop abusing
opioids
so he opened up to men's health in a
very real real way he said people are
always like did you go to rehab
and i say no i was in a plane crash that
was my rehab lose three of your friends
and almost die
that was my wake-up call if i wasn't in
a crash i probably would have never quit
he said he smoked an excessive amount of
weed prior to the crash
and abused painkillers so much as a
method of coping with his fear of flying
that he developed osteoporosis
while in the hospital for 11 weeks
following the crash he frequently came
to during surgeries because his opioid
tolerance was so high
upon his release he said he flushed
everything down the toilet including
stuff that i
quote really needed after undergoing 26
surgeries and multiple skin grafts
after burns covered 60 of his body he
said he needed to learn how to walk
again
he said quote i was told i wasn't going
to run again because i had so many
graphs on my feet and there was even
talk of me never playing the drums again
as soon as i could walk i could
i could run as soon as i could move my
hands and my hands healed i was playing
drums and now i'm in better shape than
i've ever been
wow the n also i just saw he just got a
new tattoo
what is survivor's guilt which was dark
and really sad and
i think a lot of people um especially
like younger people don't really know
travis barker's story
but now he's been in the news a lot with
courtney and his kids and there's just
like all this stuff
i think a lot of people are learning
about him and i think that he is an
amazing story that's so crazy like so
crazy i knew that he survived the plane
crash but i didn't know that his
recovery was so hard and i didn't know
that he was
struggling with addiction at the time
which i mean waking up during surgery is
my worst nightmare like
i've never gotten surgery and i'm like i
would have gotten like so much
liposuction by now
if i wasn't like really really afraid of
anesthesia because i saw this episode of
niptuck one time
isn't liposuction outpatient though like
you go under
yeah oh trust me like i've researched it
um but i saw this episode of nip tuck
once where this girl
it's like you want to just bring up
traumatizing episodes yeah that's what
that was literally
that's your goal today because if it
lives in my mind rent free you're all
going to have to suffer too there was a
it's an urban legend
of anesthesia like it's not entirely
impossible but
i don't know anyone who's ever actually
seen it and ben's uh
uncle or cousin is an anesthesiologist
like every time i see him i bring it up
um he's like it is a it's amazing he
must love him he said it's a myth but
it's not entirely impossible
where basically you have an adverse
reaction to the anesthesia and instead
of being you know put
into like a sleep coma you
actually instead become completely
paralyzed like your body
your you can't move any of your limbs
but you're fully conscious and awake
so it's like they think you're asleep
because you look like you're asleep but
you're actually feeling every
ounce of it and then the episode of
niptunk the doctors didn't believe her
but then she started to recite things
they were saying during surgery and then
they believed her
niptuck is a crazy [ __ ] show thank
you for watching i watch bits and pieces
i think everybody just wants to thank
you for bringing that up again
in such vivid detail i never forgot it
so neither should you just always keep
that in the back of your mind
yeah thanks any other add a new segment
to the show
traumatic episodes you want to bring up
there's that one of law and order that
we
oh that one that one
was absolutely terrifying i'll never
forget it especially because like
growing up we used to love a trundle
oh that then there's two you're right
okay okay okay let me start from the
beginning
the first episode of law order svu that
literally haunts me to this day
is there was a family who like was
literally keeping like a
a slave as like a housekeeper and they
literally used to make her sleep in this
cage in a trundle bed so they were like
searching the house and they couldn't
find
where they were hiding and then elliott
like pulled her out
and i'll just never forget what that
trundle looked like because
growing up trundles are like very 90s
our home was very nineties and every
single room in our house had a trundle
bed and like when we we always used to
love to sleep together as kids and it's
like oh you get on the trundle like
trundle trundle trundle tronda was like
a huge part of our lives
and then like literally there dick wolf
goes like ruining my favorite childhood
piece of furniture
that was the first one that triggered me
and then the second one i literally i
don't know what the second one is
i stopped watching svu like as
frequently after this episode when i was
in high school i was at my friend
rachel's house we were watching svu
before bed and she fell asleep so like i
finished the episode by myself and i've
watched a lot of episodes of svu
and none of them really quite you know
got to me because i was you know pretty
jaded at that point
but it was where liv goes undercover in
a prison and iced tea is there too
to kind of like make sure nothing bad
really happens to her but they're
investigating this prison guard who
is raping the inmates trigger warning
sorry um
and iced tea like is [ __ ] something
up
and he's like waiting in line or
whatever he gets lost in the prison he's
there as a guard
and liv gets left alone with this evil
prison guard and it's like the scare
and ice he's like so late getting there
to like help her
it was literally the most traumatizing i
i actually stopped watching svu after
that for a while because it was so
triggering yeah so that's my story
thanks for sharing yeah i'll if i think
of any more i'll be sure to
share yeah i'm sure you will think of
more no they just haven't come up in
conversation yet you know okay i'm sure
we'll make them
are you ready for our next story which
is definitely shifting gears oh yeah i
think we'd love to go to something
lighter
yeah because it's a little casting news
for a documentary
about a real person which we love to
know joseph gordon gordon-levitt will be
playing
ex-uber ceo travis kalonick in an
upcoming showtime anthology series
this is what is the t on the uber seat i
don't know what are we hearing things
about i'm so
interested to watch it because like we
said uber takes all of our money yet
they make none
and they've been taking all of my money
swear to god since i was a senior in
high school 100
the series titled super pumped hails
from billion show runners
brian koppelman and david levion um
billions is such a great show so this
bodes really well
for um the uber project yeah no i would
definitely be interested to see this
because
one uber is always one of those
companies that um
we refer to as like being the biggest
companies in the world that make no
money
two i think there's also a lot of really
interesting celebrities involved in uber
like i know that beyonce and jay-z were
like first-round investors ashton and
mila
so i'd just like to hear a little bit
about that and then also travis got like
kicked out right he had to step down
yeah the first season is based on mike
isaac's best-selling book super pumped
the battle for uber it will depict the
roller coaster ride of the upstart
transportation company
embodying the highs and lows of silicon
valley yeah because travis is like
disgraced yeah i think he's a disgrace i
think he's a disgraced queen
so um and i don't know why i don't know
why
we'll we'll see in the show but that's
like a show to spell it out for you
drama that you just couldn't follow in
real life
yeah and i think just also a documentary
on uber is really interesting because
uber is one of those companies there's a
ton of billion dollar companies
but this is like one of the like maybe
five that like change the way
we lived forever and then of course like
lyft and
all those other copycats but like uber
created like a shift in literally like
how people operate on an everyday basis
and i just want to know like more about
it yeah i agree i think it's going to be
a really good show it has all the
makings and joseph gordon levitt will be
playing
oh yeah i mean i don't know what travis
looks like so i don't know if he looks
but joseph gordon-levitt is a fabulous
they don't look
alike but they don't look dissimilar you
said it's a documentary so no it's not a
documentary
it's a documentary in the title i said
showtime anthology series
you literally said cast in a documentary
you said that oh i did i
did say something like that sorry um you
know like a portrayal oh
even better yeah i love a dramatized
moment it's fiction it's dramatized oh
i'll watch that for sure well it's
non-fiction
that's always confusing non-fiction is
not real non-fiction is real
cool okay what's the word for when
something is based on a true story but
they're obviously taking creative
liberties because you weren't there for
all the conversations and they're making
up conversations i think that's still
fiction
you think but it's like is fiction real
fiction is fake
oh [ __ ] based on a true story wait can
we
just go back okay non-fiction okay it's
real
non-fiction is real okay because my book
was non-fiction and i did not lie in my
book
available on amazon girls no job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster
it is a new york times bestseller also
made the wall street journalist toronto
star was kind of like an international
thing
uh check it out yeah it was an
international thing no like the
canadians were breaking
and i do believe i sold like one book in
like london you know
counts the le the royals were quaking
the royal
the only one um okay back to this a good
it is confusing non-fiction should mean
not real
not wait so fiction fiction is fake
yeah that's confusing fiction is space
well i guess that makes sense a
fictional character
duh yeah yeah now it makes sense but i
remember being in
like grade school and i was like this is
twisted turn it around turn it around
turn the beat around
left to hip percussion
are you ready for our fifth and final
story nonetheless it's the fifth and
final story that's brought to you by
scentbird
it is the final sponsor
okay have you ever had someone come up
to you and say you smell amazing what
perfume you're wearing
whatever scent you may be wearing you
have good taste and you know what you
like but your great taste is also
expensive and you end up with a shelf
full of half used bottles
or you've been wearing the same two
perfumes for years because going out to
buy a new one is a hassle
but with scentbird we have found a way
to have a great taste and mix up our
fragrance routine without breaking the
bank whether it's from tom ford gucci
verasache scentbird.com keeps us
smelling good month to month
so sun bird is a fragrant subscription
service that gives you the opportunity
to skip
to shop from over 600 brands it's
flexible
so you can skip any month without
penalties they let you choose a designer
fragrance every month to try from for
just 16
each month you get to pick what you want
to receive so there are no surprises
they have perfumes and colognes and a
bunch of unisex options
they carry the top designers like prada
gucci versace and indie ones like vince
camuto the harmonist
and confessions of a rebel all of them
are 100 authentic they work directly
with the brands
but if you're not sure what type of
scent you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance by brand
style occasion season and more some
bottles can cost anywhere from 150
to 500 bottles which is insane imagine
spending that much money on a bottle and
then you end up not even liking it so
with senpur you can get a decent amount
of high-end fragrance for just 16
the best part is the little things they
come in they're so travel friendly you
don't need a whole bottle you almost
never use it and if you don't even like
it you can change it the next month it's
perfect
and we have a code and it'll just be 11
as opposed to 16 for your first month
so get 30 off your first month today
eleven dollars for your first fragrance
at sendford.com and use the code toast
for thirty percent off your first month
again that's
s c e n t bird dot com
for you to try your first perfume or
cologne for just eleven dollars
sign
they took a hiatus from sponsoring and i
was like missing them and now they're
back
three for three on sponsors yeah love to
see public goods is
is honestly everything i feel so like
elegant and rich
you are i am are you ready for our fifth
and final story sure it's a little
merger news that hasn't happened yet but
it's about to happen that could change
the game
i absolutely love an m a story that's
mergers and acquisitions for those who
don't know for those who don't work in
finance like us i know some of you are
from new jersey
honestly jackie quoting my award-winning
comedy special
disgraced queen available on amazon
prime to stream for free
um really there's no greater joy like
than knowing that the art you put out
there is clearly resonating with a young
mind
no those are like you have tic-tac
sounds i have
quotes from your disgrace yeah yeah i
just feel like i haven't talked about
like a lot of my projects in a while i
went really hard promoting in june for
my
comedy special then like really hard in
january reporting my book and i would
just kind of have these like successful
projects and i don't really
talk about them which is like because
i'm so humble you know yeah but i guess
it's also like
on to the next one yeah even though i
have literally nothing in the pipeline
well speaking of amazon amazon is
nearing a deal to buy the hollywood
studio mgm holdings
for almost nine billion dollars
including debt said people familiar with
the matter
that's crazy oh my god the film
landscape is constantly
constantly evolving a pack that would
turn a film operation founded in the
silent era into a streaming asset for
the e-commerce giant
giant an agreement could be announced as
early as this week people close to the
situation said
assuming the talks talks don't fall
through at the last
minute that's insane like that is
literally like
a groundbreaking merger and acquisition
that will forever change the landscape
of cinema 100
the silver screen and it would be the
second biggest acquisition in
amazon's history first the first was the
three 13.7 billion dollar purchase of
whole foods remember that
i just felt like that was like really
unnecessary no i mean now that it
happened i'm like yeah no they
needed to own like grocery stores so
they could become like you know prime
now and all that stuff
yeah i just like the i like despise
whole foods like yeah and this is a
really hot tape because i know there are
people whose literal personality traits
is like knowing all the products at
whole foods and
trader joe's i actually don't mind
trader joe's they're different i think
those are different
like low-key fattening and that's why i
don't mind it yeah but like whole foods
with like all their like chia seed
pudding like
get the [ __ ] away from me and there's
one on every corner and it's like what
happened to the regular grocery store
it's like what happened to like
food mart you know and like key food
like yeah give me the regular grocery
stores
yeah no i don't think that will come as
a surprise to anyone
that i don't [ __ ] with whole foods you
don't [ __ ] with whole foods but that you
might [ __ ] with trader joe's except i do
have to say like low-key whole foods has
like really cheap orchids that last for
like
six years oh nice they also have a nice
uh fish mart and that's if i'm ever
getting
if i'm ever cooking fish at home i can
trust that their fish is fresh
no i my mouth is watering just thinking
about it for dinner tonight i'll make
you some whole foods fish
i'm okay but thank you so much for the
imitation the offer always stands i know
and that's why you're such a good sister
um but back to this this is like low-key
crazy because this is like really
the streaming wars are heating up and
now they're in consolidation mode okay
so like the war
is here and now we're we're recruiting
allies right because like
if you as long as you think about it
like the the studios when you watch
entourage and then you watch like
hollywood on netflix which is from the
50s like
the major studios like mgm fox paramount
like
they have really kind of controlled the
film
cinema landscape i can't stop saying
that for
as long as movies have been around yeah
so it's like this is like a
a huge shift like we are really moving
into the digital age and like i thought
we were already here but we're not
yeah no but it is a huge shift sheriff
um and this is actually a great topic to
bring up if you're invited to a dinner
party
at any kind of point in the next week
100 and what's interesting is that in
december mgm was valued about 5.5
billion dollars they also have
two billion dollars in debt please make
that make sense like okay so
they're 5.5 2 billion so they should be
3.5 but yet they're valued at 9 billion
even though literally no one has been to
the movies in a year and not a single
movie has really been released in the
last year
make it make sense this is giving me we
work vibes well
i don't i i'm not going to purport to
know everything but i would imagine
like everything that mgm has ever made
james bond yeah etc now would be on
amazon prime like that catalog just got
huge that's very true and they have like
i don't know i mean i guess amazon has
studios and they're making their own
shows like mgm has those lots and all
these shows and like
now all of that goes to amazon and they
don't have to lift a finger like all
their assets
yeah that's true i guess like you know
what's so crazy is like amazon like
shits out nine billion dollars like they
will
be completely unaffected by the loss of
nine billion dollars they're a trillion
dollar company correct
so i mean but it hasn't happened yet and
maybe i don't know maybe this episode
like someone will hear something be like
oh yeah that's not a good idea no but
like i actually think it's a good idea
i think it makes a lot of sense too and
honestly like i just wake up every day
and like can't believe that and come up
with the idea for amazon first like i'm
so mad
i know but they really snuck up on us i
know like i remember
like because it was just books you know
i remember like being in camp and like
hiding my blackberry and like literally
needing something and like ordering like
sunblock on amazon and it was like
i was so innovative everyone's like you
ordered from amazon like it was i'm like
yeah no amazon is everything you guys
don't realize like they even
have makeup yeah they have like bathing
suits and like when we were like
counselors at camp like
10 years ago we would like order it was
like amazon but like
i just i can't believe how big it's
gotten i know and then i guess like we
were really on the cusp of ordering
everything from amazon
and then i guess everyone caught on and
that's why it's trillions but like i
feel very cool to know that like when
i've been a prime member for
like literally since i think maybe when
i was in high school and two like
i ordered amazon like when you know
before like it was cool you know yeah no
i agree i feel the same
about myself yeah we were just like so
we and that's why we have the successful
morning show like we're constantly on
the cusp on the cutting edge of like
what is cool
yeah and we're choogy while we do it 100
speaking of what's cool
these do you like tickets you like that
you can't stop staring at them oh my god
thank you so much i got them from
dollskill
unbelievably sickeningly so unchewy of
you
thank you so much so like i need to
figure out how to style them i went like
with a you know i didn't take any
chances today
but i feel like with summer like i'll
probably wear them with shorts which is
just like really
scary for like my calves no you're so so
cool
thank you so much for noticing and i'm
just wearing like a chewy ass outfit as
always
i'm okay with it like i've come to terms
yeah um
you're not chewy on the inside and
that's what matters i think we should
wrap up the episode because we've just
kind of been sitting here for a while
and like there's no sound from
construction and i just don't want to
push our luck
yeah i don't want to push our luck and
you know people got to get back to work
they gave us our space 40
quiet minutes and we are so grateful and
we will you know and maybe if we could
give a few minutes back to them
that would be the last week that would
bode well for the next time they know
they can trust us to be on time with
those quiet minutes
you guys so tomorrow we're gonna podcast
from home yeah i think it's for the best
yeah i think it's for the best too
thank you guys so much for the they're
done at the end of the week with all
this nonsense so
after memorial day weekend a long time
being longer
hopefully i don't want to jinx it things
would be quiet thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have already cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we hope you guys have an amazing
truly spectacular day
we'll see you tomorrow for a podcast
only episode yes goodbye goodbye
you